One of the best things about doing the critical memory path analysis is you
can get a pretty good estimate for how long the page will take to render.
>> Yeah, it's pretty awesome. Once I have
my critical rendering path diagram I don't even
have to profile my page. Well, I do
need to profile my page for other bottlenecks, but
what I mean is that I can see all the dependencies in my critical rendering path
diagram and get a good idea of how long my page is going to take to render.
>> Exactly. With a little bit of practice you
can just take a look at the XML and figure out what the critical
rendering path is. And you know what,
that's actually a great exercise. I'm going to
give you a couple of files which you can find in the instructor notes, and
why don't you analyze those, draw the
diagrams, and come up with the CRP metrics.
>> So should I draw a diagram like the ones we've been seeing in the examples?
>> Yep, exactly. And don't worry about making it pretty. Use whatever tools
you like. Pen and paper is good, and then post it on the forum.
>> Alright, so I'll make sure I've
got the three critical rendering path metrics too.
The critical path length the number of
critical resources, and the number of critical bytes.
>> Yep. Exactly.
>> Cool, so I'll go ahead and post it on the forums.